The joe rogan experience.
What are you guys gonna play?
Oh,
sorry.
We can play a song called big man.
My good friends.
The only band I've ever worked with ever.
In real life.
What are you gonna play?
Big Man.
What's happening?
That's the song.
We're going to play real life.
Well,
the only with us,
Tony played some drums.
I feel like you could get some drums.
I want to just watch.
Do too many things.
Play drums.
Super Group
means skin on
the penis.
Obvious here.
This.
Okay guys.
Let it go.
Hey,
how's that work?
Oh,
good.
Yup.
Okay.
Oh,
when the pig man,
they spill Bucky.
Oh
no
man,
baby.
Okay,
wait.
Ooh.
And they came,
uh,
to the funeral.
Hey Jay called.
Hey.
Damn man.
Okay.
You can try her head off baby.
Oh,
part of some big plan.
Maybe no one should ever low
down low
bones buried
bones.
Barry de Bono's out wall shea
to sleep
and he
same
old pain.
Yeah.
Awesome.
That's a beautiful song.
Shit.
Nice mine.
Is that one of the ones going
to be in the new special?
That's it.
Yeah.
That's what you're shooting for.
Do you guys have a name for the record?
No,
not yet,
but we're open to ideas.
Okay.